[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver à
la Une de star warguard ce soir
l'urgence sanitaire commande l'état
d'urgence les députés vont approuver ce
week-end sa prorogation jusqu'au 16
février prochain le texte prévoit même
des restrictions de liberté au-delà de
cette date alors la progression de
l'épidémie justifie-t-elle de mettre le
Parlement sous cloche va-t-on vers un
état d'urgence permanent c'est notre
grand débat ce soir notre grand témoin
lui ne décolère pas contre la gestion de
cette crise par le gouvernement dans son
livre il parle même de fiasco français
sur les masques sur les tests il avait
dès 2004 rédigé un plan anti-épidémie
resté dans les tiroirs l'ancien ministre
de la Santé Philippe Douste Blazy est
avec nous ce soir sans oublier bien sûr
le bloc-notes du vendredi avec tous nos
chroniqueurs François Durpaire a regardé
pour nous le dernier débat Trump Biden
la chronique de Thomas Desprez et puis
l'apéro de Camille safari avec un député
voilà vous savez tout c'est parti tout
de suite le grand départ
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi LCP
bonsoir Philippe Douste Blaise merci
d'être notre grand témoin maladie
françaises pandémie et pourtant tout
avait été préparé cette aux éditions de
l'archipel avec une préface du
professeur Didier Raoult on va en parler
longuement dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission c'est une charge lourde
on l'a compris avec le titre contre la
gestion de la crise sanitaire mais
d'abord on va s'interroger sur cette
nouvelle prorogation de l'état d'urgence
le vote a eu lieu en commission hier
soir les députés planches tout le
week-end dans l'hémicycle vote devrait
avoir lieu donc pour et bien proroger
toutes les mesures restrictives de
liberté on va en parler avec vous
Pierre-Alexandre Anglade bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes député la République en marche
des Français du Benelux Belgique
Pays-Bas Luxembourg et vous débattez ce
soir avec Sébastien Huyck bienvenue vous
êtes député les républicains du Nord et
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam Stéphane
blackovski qui va tout de suite ouvrir
le bal avec son billet d'actu si j'ai
bien compris tout de suite
[Musique]
Stéphane si j'ai bien compris ce soir si
j'ai bien compris Myriam nous sommes
dans une telle situation d'urgence
sanitaire que le gouvernement n'a pas de
temps à perdre pour discuter avec les
députés des meilleurs manières de lutter
contre le covid alors du coup il espère
faire voter un projet de loi donc dès
demain qui va permettre de prolonger
l'état d'urgence vous l'avez dit
jusqu'au 16 février ce qui lui permettra
de prendre toutes les mesures qu'il
estime nécessaire contre le covid sans
être obligé d'en discuter de s'en
discuter de bien fonder de ses décisions
alors évidemment une petite objection on
serait tenté de faire c'est est-ce que
discuter avec les députés c'est vraiment
perdre du temps c'est un peu ça la
question qu'on se pose parce que en tout
cas il semblerait que Olivier était pas
loin de penser ça hier devant la
commission des lois il a pas hésité à
dramatiser un petit peu la situation en
disant chaque minute était précieuse et
que pendant que les disputés les députés
étaient en train de discuter et bien oui
le covid lui faisait des ravages
hier dans notre pays il y a eu plus de
2000 patients hospitalisés et plus de
250 patients hospitalisées en
réanimation ça fait presque une
hospitalisation par minute c'est-à-dire
depuis que j'ai commencé à parler il y a
cinq personnes qui sont à l'hôpital donc
clairement consultant le Parlement le
gouvernement craint perdre du temps bah
oui c'est ce que l'air de dire Olivier
range chaque minute est précieuse donc
grâce à l'état d'urgence l'avantage avec
le gouvernement va pouvoir légifrer par
ordonnance dire en limitant le temps de
discussion avec l'opposition qui risque
évidemment de pas toujours être d'accord
avec lui alors ce goût du gouvernement
pour les ordonnances en même temps c'est
pas nouveau on lui a déjà reproché
auparavant nombreuses réformes ont été
menées par ordonnance depuis le début la
SNCF les retraites la loi travail à tel
point qu'en juin dernier le journal Le
Monde avait voulu savoir est-ce que
vraiment Emmanuel Macron est le champion
des ordonnances parmi les présidents
qu'on a eu et ben pas du tout
figurez-vous le champion des ordonnances
c'était son prédécesseur François
Hollande qui a encore plus utilisé le
système des ordonnances que
Emmanuel Macron alors s'il n'est pas le
champion des ordonnances Emmanuel Macron
l'opposition trouve quand même qu'il a
besoin un peu c'est ça ouais
d'utiliser les ordonnances dans cette
situation là où trouve que c'est abusé
c'est de décider que ils vont pouvoir le
faire pendant une si longue période
parce que l'état d'urgence donc là doit
du vrai jusqu'au 16 février ça donc déjà
4 mois pendant lequel pas de discussion
sur les décisions covid mais il devrait
y avoir en plus ça va pas s'arrêter d'un
coup l'état d'urgence il y avoir une
période transitoire de deux mois donc ça
fait 6 mois ou finalement le Parlement
va être un peu mis de côté bah d'où la
réaction de Georges Paul Langevin hier
devant la commune à la Commission
le texte tel qu'il nous est présenté et
privilégie évidemment la sécurité
sanitaire sur les libertés fondamentales
mais peut-on accepter de le faire sur
une durée aussi longue pratiquement
jusqu'au mois d'avril prochain et compte
tenu de l'ensemble des habilitations que
le gouvernement demande pratiquement
c'est le pouvoir législatif qui sera à
l'arrêt donc le gouvernement a décidé à
lui seul de gérer cette crise c'est ça
libres sans qu'on vienne constamment lui
faire des objections par exemple sur le
respect des libertés fondamentales alors
sans doute que ça donne aux sentiments
le sentiment gourmand de pouvoir être
plus efficace cet état d'urgence mais il
faut quand même rappeler qu'aujourd'hui
quand on regarde les sondages en France
il n'y a que 36% des Français qui font
confiance au gouvernement dans sa
gestion de la crise c'est 10 points de
moins que la moyenne qui existe en
Europe quand on demande la vie aux
Européens sur l'attitude de leur
gouvernement donc la question qu'on se
pose c'est face à ce manque de confiance
des Français est-ce que finalement ça
serait pas une bonne idée d'écouter un
peu plus les députés qui justement sont
les représentants des Français merci
pour cette bonne question et ce billet
Stéphane la question vous est posée au
fond pourquoi le gouvernement ne
s'appuie pas davantage même si
évidemment la crise sanitaire commande
de pouvoir faire des restrictions
liberté sur le Parlement il s'agit aussi
de donner confiance aux Français mais je
crois que le Parlement a été très
largement consulté depuis le début de
cette crise il y a eu je crois que si on
met bout à bout l'ensemble des débats
législatifs qui ont pu occuper le
Parlement depuis le début de la crise
covid plus de 80 heures de débat sur le
sujet le Parlement a été consulté au
mois de mars évidemment au moment de la
première installation de l'état
d'urgence a été consulté ensuite
régulièrement pendant la crise il y a eu
la sortie de l'état d'urgence au mois de
juillet qui nous a occupés il y a eu
en parallèle les commissions d'enquête
diverses et variées au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale qui ont permis
d'interroger assez largement le
gouvernement sur l'action qui avait été
la sienne dans les premiers instants de
la crise et puis il y a évidemment
hebdomadaire de façon hebdomadaire les
questions au Gouvernement dans
lesquelles les députés de la majorité et
de l'opposition peuvent solliciter le
ministre de la Santé le Premier ministre
et tous les ministres du gouvernement
sur tous les aspects de la crise je ne
pense pas que le je ne pense pas je ne
pense pas que le Parlement soit
court-circuté ou mis sous cloche comme
on pourrait l'entendre pendant cette
crise non
extraordinaire des temps de doute des
temps qui inquiètent largement nos
concitoyens qui exigent parfois une
réactivité de la part du gouvernement et
qui exige aussi d'avoir ces outils un
petit peu extraordinaires mais après
effectivement je comprends la position
d'opposition qui peut être plus allant
sur un débat soutenu mais en l'état je
ne crois pas
écoutez moi ça me désole d'entendre un
député de la République dire que il y a
pas besoin finalement du Parlement
la réalité la réalité c'est quoi c'est
que à plusieurs reprises le gouvernement
a demandé les pleins pouvoirs pour avoir
les coups des Francs et
l'opinion des Français est très
illustrative ils n'ont pas confiance
dans le gouvernement pour gérer la crise
et ils ont raison parce que le
gouvernement
c'est pas c'est exactement la même chose
là le gouvernement et en échec
[Musique]
sur tous les plans dans cette crise
d'ailleurs Philippe doute Blasi qui
connaît bien qu'il connaît bien le sujet
on a fait tout un bouquin pour expliquer
tous les échecs c'est à dire que il a
demandé dans le cadre de
cette prorogation ce sont les mesures ou
c'est la date de prorogation jusqu'au 7
février franchement en train de voter au
Parlement c'était la prorogation de la
sortie d'état d'urgence et ce texte est
brus simplement arrêté à cause du
couvre-feu parce que on vient nous
remettre un texte sur l'état d'urgence
or le texte de sortie d'état d'urgence
qu'on était en train de prologer qui
était qui avait été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale et qui était en train d'être
discuter au Sénat on était en fin de
discussion au Sénat et bien permettait
toutes les mesures qui sont mises en
place par le gouvernement la seule chose
qui n'est pas possible avec ce texte
c'est de
couvre-feu également le couvre-feu il
était bon retour de l'état d'urgence
absolument pas le texte permettait de
continuer le couvre-feu la seule chose
qui nécessite l'état d'urgence en tant
que tel c'est le reconfinement et donc
si le gouvernement souhaite
réinstituer l'état d'urgence pour
pouvoir faire un reconfinement il doit
être transparent et le dire aujourd'hui
le gouvernement ne le dit pas et j'ai
l'impression qu'on prend des vessies
pour des lanternes
la ville le gouvernement a reconfinement
partiel avec ce qu'on connaît déjà des
des données de l'épidémie on entend dire
que la deuxième vague serait pire que la
première personne ne peut dire ce qui va
se passer dans 15 jours 3 semaines 1
mois et ceux qui vous font croire qu'il
le savent ne le savent pas de toute
façon ce qu'on sait c'est que lorsqu'on
a confiné la première fois les résultats
se sont le début des résultats était
trois semaines après ça c'est la seule
chose donc on peut pas savoir ce que
vont donner ce couvre-feu on n'est pas
15 jours
je vous remercie de votre invitation
mais je suis très heureux de revenir ici
dans cette maison que je connais bien
j'étais président de groupe et
j'entendais les deux députés si vous
voulez mon avis je vais mettre le pied
dans le plat je pense
que en matière de santé lorsqu'il y a
une crise sanitaire aussi grave que
celle là ce qui nous a manqué en fait
c'est bâtons les discussions avec des
heures et des autres c'est un chef
d'état-major voilà un système en France
qu'il faut mettre en place où il y a le
ministère de la santé mais aussi le
ministère de l'Intérieur pourquoi pas le
ministère de fer étrangère avec vous
sur la chaîne de commandement sur la
bureaucratie il faut à tout prix si vous
voulez que l'on puisse mettre en place
un système de crise avec des gens qui
sont habitués aux crises
sur l'état d'urgence jusqu'à quand le
Parlement il est il est secondaire
aujourd'hui on regarde ce qu'on traverse
des Françaises et les Français ont
besoin de d'une personne qui connaît
particulièrement bien le sujet des
épidémies
et qui donne à l'exécutif à cet homme
d'indications parce que être chef de
l'État aujourd'hui ou Premier ministre
aujourd'hui c'est quand même pas évident
moi j'ai aucune leçon à donner
simplement je pense qu'on manque de chef
d'état-major puisse dire ça ça et ça ça
ne se discute pas
il existe c'est le Président c'est
justement alors non parce que
figurez-vous que le Président de la
République peut-être que vous le savez
pas mais ni épidémiologiste ni
infectiologue il est tout à fait normal
qu'il demande la vie de Jean éclairé et
dans tous les pays du monde demande la
vie de scientifiques justement souvent
sans pas d’accord entre eux c'est pour
ça que je vous dis qu'il faut un chef
d'état-major on n'a pas eu de chefs on a
eu on a l'impression que vous voulez
qu'un médecin décide mais c'est pas au
médecin décider
non un chef d'état-major c'est pas un
médecin comme vous dites non ce qui a
manqué c'est que aujourd'hui il y avait
le Conseil Scientifique la Haute
Autorité de santé que j'ai créée quand
j'étais mise à la santé vous aviez
l'Académie de médecine vous aviez je
peux vous faire toute la liste c'est 5 6
régionales de santé
la directeur la Direction Générale de
Santé vous avez trop de monde qui son
avis à un moment donné ces gens doivent
donner leur avis et à la fin monsieur il
faut qu'il y ait une personne qui soit
devant dire tous les Français et qui
donnent son avis au président et là vous
avez raison c'est que c'est le président
infini qui décide bien sûr mais il est
fondamental qu'il y a un chef
d'état-majorité c'est pas suffisant il
est disqualifié pour vous mais là j'ai
pas dit non j'ai dit que le Conseil
Scientifique jouait un rôle important
mais que il fallait que au dessus il y a
quelqu'un qui va revenir parce que c'est
un des constats que vous faites dans
votre livre mais je voudrais qu'on
vienne à l'état d'urgence c'est le thème
de notre débat vous vous dites quoi aux
Français qui nous regardent ne vous
inquiétez pas le Parlement est
suffisamment consulté et au fond au
députés qui vous disent on est en train
d'aller jusqu'au 1er avril c'est normal
le président de la République a dit que
l'épidémie irait jusqu'à l'été peut-être
même la fin de l'été ça veut dire qu'on
ira jusqu'à l'été pour l'état d'urgence
vient de dire des choses extrêmement
justes sur l'état de la situation
sanitaire du pays et effectivement
aujourd'hui personne ne peut dire
jusqu'en jusqu'à quand ira cette
épidémie et donc celles et ceux qui
depuis 48 heures ou trois semaines nous
disent qu'il y a une seconde vague
extrêmement puissante mais qu'au fond
elle sera même beaucoup plus forte que
la première dans sa vraie de la même
façon celles et ceux qui vous disent
qu'on ira jusqu'à regarder juste les
chiffres
sont importants mais les chiffres sont
importants partout en Europe et ce que
les gens doivent comprendre c'est que ce
n'est pas un phénomène exclusivement
français bien sûr qu'il y a eu des
défaillances dans les premiers temps de
la crise et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est largement reconnu par la majorité
c'est largement reconnu par le
gouvernement et le président lui-même
qui a fait un moment d'honorable sur le
sujet de vous les citer
41622 nouveau 4 covid 41 622 c'est un
record en 24 heures
on teste beaucoup plus que nous testions
à l'époque par ailleurs la France est un
pays extrêmement peuplé et lorsque
j'entends que la France a battu un
record européen aujourd'hui en ayant ou
la hier en ayant eu 41 000 passants
patient c'était positif au covid il faut
remettre ça dans une perspective dans le
fait dans le fait que la France est
extrêmement peuplé effectivement
l'Allemagne réussit un petit peu mieux
que nous en ce moment mais la situation
aussi en Allemagne se dégrade moi je
suis élu d'une circonscription du Nord
de l'Europe au Pays-Bas on est en train
de prendre des mesures extrêmement
coercitives qui serait perçu en France
comme des atteints très fortes au
Liberté la fermeture des bars et des
restaurants d'une façon drastique en
Belgique les bars tous les bars et
restaurants sont totalement fermés avec
en plus un couvre-feu c'est pas ils sont
fermés le soir à 21h ils sont fermés
pendant un mois le Pays de Galles
reconfine l'Irlande reconfine la
République tchèque Europe centrale on
pensait que c'était un espace d'Europe
plutôt préservé dans la crise non mais
moi écoutez je pense que tout est fait
mais je ne sais pas je ne sais rien je
pense qu'il faut avoir beaucoup
d'humidité dans cette crise et admettre
que l'on ne sait pas non non
parce que c'est vrai qu'on ne peut pas
d'abord faire de la politique
politicienne avec ça ça je crois qu'on
peut pas puis c'est trop grave mais
regardez les chiffres vous avez donné
des chiffres extrêmement intéressant
et c'est ça qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que aujourd'hui d'abord vous avez
beaucoup de cas qui sont évidemment une
une incidence qui augmente de 40 %
durant la dernière semaine donc ça c'est
évidemment extrêmement préoccupant
deuxièmement regardez les livres
réanimation vous avez aujourd'hui 28%
38% de leadspitalisation en réa qui sont
utilisés peu et qui sont utilisés par
des gens covid c'était 100% dans
certaines régions c'est bien sûr mais en
moyenne c'est 38% c'était 100% mais il
faut le dire la vérités et deuxièmement
il faut regarder aussi quelle est la
moyenne d'âge des gens qui décèdent
c'est 84 ans donc il faut le dire ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas mettre de
masque oui il faut le mettre de masque
oui il faut faire déjà il doit écrire
alcoolique mais des confinements
j'arrivais à ça c'est que moi je crois
en tout cas moi je ferai mise de la
santé aujourd'hui je pense je ferai
partie de ceux qui les écoutaient je
n'ai aucune je vais pas discriminer les
personnes au-delà de 65 ans dont je suis
je vais pas les obliger à être confinés
mais je vais quand même les mettre là
vous avez à nouveau la question de
l'État de droit parce que quand
l'exécutif a essayé de mettre cette
question sur les tables
constitutionnel immédiatement à voilà
enfin a été susceptible de d'être saisi
et vous avez une organisation élevée de
bouclier
et leur dire prenez vos responsabilités
le gros problème c'est l'acte
l'acceptation des mesures par la
population si elles ne sont pas
acceptées elles ne sont pas appliquées
et le gros problème c'est que comme il y
a eu beaucoup de cafouillages beaucoup
de nos concitoyens n'ont plus confiance
dans ce qu'on vous refaites parce
qu'aujourd'hui le couvre-feu il est très
bien respecté je ne refais pas le match
j'arrive le problème c'est que Philippe
Douste Blazy dit il manque un chef
d'orchestre il manque effectivement sur
moins cher moi dit il manque une
stratégie et une stratégie qui soit
claire parce que si le gouvernement
disait aux Français lorsqu'on est dans
tel cas on prend telle mesure lorsqu'on
est dans tel niveau d'incidence c'est le
couvre-feu sur tel territoire lorsque
l'on va arriver à tel autre niveau de
confinement et si les choses sont dites
de manière claire transparente à
l'avance et que on démontre français
qu'on a une stratégie pour lutter contre
le virus et bien là de prévoir quand
c'est aussi une crise de l'incertitude
et le problème c'est que le sentiment
qu'on les Français c'est que les
décisions sont pris un peu au fil de
l'eau à la petite semaine sans une
stratégie globale qui a été pensée à
l'avance pour lutter contre
je suis d'accord avec la lecture de la
nécessité absolue d'avoir une stratégie
une vision extrêmement claire de ce que
l'on doit faire pour le pays et l'avoir
des seuils où l'on l'indique aux
françaises aux Français quelle serait la
conséquence il nous arrivions à tel
épidémique dans le même temps moi des
notes que depuis la fin du confinement
Premier ministre le ministre de la Santé
le président de la République ont un
discours extrêmement consistant sur le
covid ils disent la même chose attention
le vision US est encore là respectez les
gestes entre juin et octobre
on a augmenté les lits pour la
réanimation on a commandé les masques on
a tous les on a tous les les matériaux
dont on a besoin dans les hôpitaux et
donc non ce que je veux dire c'est que
peut-être ce que je veux dire c'est que
parfois
il y a des injonctions extrêmement
contradictoires de la part de certains
l'on entend que quand le gouvernement
reprend une mesure parce que la
situation serait difficile je pense par
exemple à ce qui c'est a pu se passer à
Marseille on nous dit ouh là là
attention mais non le virus à Marseille
est sous contrôle il y a pas besoin de
prendre des mesures extrêmement
draconiennes et puis quelques semaines
après à mesure que la l'épidémie
progresse et de façon encore plus forte
les mêmes qui vous disaient ne prenons
pas de mesure trop de draconiennes parce
que le virus sous contrôle appelle à des
mesures extrêmement coercitives pour
répondre à la crise et au virus et donc
ce que je dis c'est que les injonctions
contradictoires les messages qui
viennent dans tous les sens qui viennent
perturber et fouiller la perception des
Français elles sont à mon avis largement
partagées dans le débat public français
je voudrais qu'on vienne à notre sujet
parce que ensuite on va parler de la
crise sanitaire et de la gestion la
gestion passée de ce gouvernement l'état
d'urgence c'est la restriction de
liberté aujourd'hui vous on regarde le
couvre-feu il est plutôt bien respecté
parce que ça sera pas toujours le cas
mais en tout cas c'est le cas
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez
l'application la nouvelle application
stop covid je sais plus où
vide voilà tout le monde veut la
télécharger on est plus du tout sur un
débat de liberté comme c'était le cas au
début de la crise on a on n'a pas été
par Google et par et par facebook mais
peut-être qu'il faut le regretter parce
que on a des applications différentes
dans d'autres dans d'autres pays donc en
fait la question c'est comment le député
de l'opposition que vous êtes ne peut
pas accompagner au fond le mouvement
puisque c'est d'urgence sanitaire elle
est au-delà des clivages nous avons dit
que le confinement était une bonne chose
qu'un certain nombre de mesures qui ont
été prises par le gouvernement étaient
dans la bonne direction
très peu de voix en tout cas chez les
républicains qui se sont élevés contre
les mesures qui ont été mises en oeuvre
par contre le problème c'est la date
c'est la manière dont on fonctionne
c'est la manière où je regrette on a le
sentiment en tout cas que il n'y a pas
de il n'y a pas de stratégie et que de
le Parlement est devenu une simple
chambre d'enregistrement regardez le
texte est passé au Conseil des ministres
mercredi hier il était en commission des
lois et il va être discuté samedi et
dimanche et donc on considère vous savez
les députés les députés normalement
s'ils font bien leur travail ils doivent
étudier le texte dans quel laps de temps
peuvent-ils étudier convenablement le
texte quand le texte sur quatre jours et
en plus dans ce texte vous avez à la
fois
l'état d'urgence mais aussi la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence ça veut
dire que on va même pas revenir devant
le Parlement pour discuter de la manière
dont on va sortir de l'état d'urgence
parce qu'on va le prévoir dès
aujourd'hui dans d'un seul tenant et
donc finalement dans six mois on va plus
en parler alors qu'on avait une autre
fenêtre de tir puisque normalement au
mois de janvier nous allons discuter
d'un texte qui va instaurer en dehors de
la période que nous vivons la
possibilité
désormais de mettre un état en place un
état d'urgence sanitaire si d'autres
pandémies au fond de la légitimité du
Parlement dans une crise sanitaire ce
matin dans Le Figaro une carte de France
où on voit le taux d'incidence pour
toutes les villes il y a des choses qui
qui sont difficiles à comprendre c'est à
dire que le taux d'incidence à Nice si
je me souviens bien il y a 167 il est
au-delà de 200 à Nantes Nice sous
couvre-feu Nantes n'allait pas donc du
nombre de personnes de plus de 65 ans
touché les vieux centaines donc
exactement
inférieur auto-national et pourtant
c'est pour les personnes de plus toutes
les Alpes-Maritimes qui sont et pas
seulement toutes les Alpes-Maritimes qui
sont couvre donc en voyant ça on peut
être en tout cas un peu perplexe comme
vous disiez peut-être pour clore ce
débat à ceux qui s'inquiètent sur sur
les libertés sur la durée de cet état
d'urgence vous leur vouloir dites quoi
on se souvient en 2015 après les
attentats François Hollande avait pris
l'état d'urgence il avait été d'ailleurs
prorogé plusieurs fois et Emmanuel
Macron a pris des mesures qui ont permis
de faire entrer dans l'État de droit les
perquisitions administratives les
assignations à résidence est-ce qu'ils
peuvent se passer la même chose avec
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
et terroriste à une crise sanitaire qui
sont deux événements évidemment distants
on vit des temps extraordinaires et que
ces temps extraordinaire parfois exige
de prendre des mesures qui le sont et
lorsque l'on prend des mesures qui
peuvent paraître attentatoires ou
restrictif d'un certain nombre de
liberté elles le sont au nom de
l'intérêt collectif et de la
préservation de la santé d'une partie de
nos concitoyens si le gouvernement si la
majorité ne prenait pas ses mesures
alors légitimement la population
pourrait tout à fait se retourner contre
nous il nous dire qu'avait ou fait pour
nous protéger donc ces mesures sont des
mesures de protection qui sont limitées
dans le temps
et qui effectivement empiète sur les
libertés de nos concitoyens pour un
temps donné mais dans le mais qui à la
fin sont là pour les protéger et par
ailleurs je le rappelle que dans la
première partie de la crise il y a eu un
certain nombre de recours qui ont été
introduits devant les tribunaux par une
partie des associations par des certains
de nos concitoyens et donc la capacité
de saisir les uns et les autres si on
avait le sentiment que son droit pouvait
être atteint et libre dans notre pays et
donc moi je pense non mais je pense
démocratique oui mais excusez-moi mais
on vit quand même un temps on vit un
temps qui est un temps singulier et moi
j'assume le fait que dans la période que
nous traversons les libertés
individuelles puissent être restreinte
au nom de la préservation
avec une limite c'est le contrôle du
Parlement or on part six mois le
Parlement
ou le gouvernement aura les mains des
rendez-vous plus réguliers pourquoi le
gouvernement voilà décide de faire ça
quelle sera la nature du débat
parlementaire et peut-être que des
clauses peut-être
dans le débat mais ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il y a un contrôle dans notre
pays de l'action du gouvernement qui est
réel et chaque semaine
pourront interroger le gouvernement lors
des questions d'actualité pourront
revenir de sous d'autres formes dans les
commissions d'enquête diverses et
variées dans les débats que nous aurons
en commission des lois sur l'état
d'urgence tel qu'il est en ce moment et
sur la situation telle qu'elle est dans
le pays donc moi je je comprends si vous
voulez la logique qui est de dire
lorsque vous êtes dans une dans
l'opposition le Parlement doit être
saisi consulter de façon régulière pour
qu'il soit associé pour que les citoyens
de ce pays puissent l'être dans la
construction de la loi en même temps
j'assume le fait que dans un temps de
crise extrêmement aiguë tout à fait
singulier que nous n'avons pas rencontré
depuis des décennies le gouvernement
puisse prendre les mesures nécessaires
pour protéger la population il manque le
contrôle de gouvernement
je reviens mais il manque véritablement
le contrôle du gouvernement et
excusez-moi vous n'allez pas nous
renvoyer à la séance de deux heures de
questions au gouvernement ou la question
est posée en deux minutes et le ministre
répond en deux minutes après le 1er
avril vous attendez par exemple
parce que on pose une question deux
minutes avec le ministre répond en deux
minutes et bien il y aura un contrôle de
gouvernement pour terminer
est-ce que vous pensez donc après le
premier avril ça va continuer
nous le verrons je pense effectivement
que tant qu'il n'y aura pas un vaccin
efficace nous resterons dans la crise
sanitaire mais ça veut dire que il y a
il va y avoir des moments de crise plus
aiguë que d'autres on l'a vécu avec cet
été ou la crise était moins aiguë mais
ce qui est important quand on est comme
cela sur la durée c'est que le Parlement
qui représente le peuple français puisse
contrôler l'action du gouvernement qui
est nommé vous l'avez dit
après avoir trouvé un vaccin parce que
le vaccin sera là se fera la question de
l'acceptabilité de ce vaccin et donc
vous verrez que les débats se
poursuivront et donc je pense que
chacune et chacun de celle qui nous
écoutent doivent être conscients que ce
débat et cette question sanitaire va
nous habiter pendant de longs mois
peut-être des années merci beaucoup
pour ce Blazy on va parler maintenant de
ce livre maladie française pandémie et
pourtant tout avait été préparé un
ancien ministre de la Santé qui sonne la
charge c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
maladie française donc pandémie et
pourtant tout avait été préparée préfacé
par le professeur Didier Raoult je le
disais vous êtes sévère vous êtes même
très dur avec cette équipe
gouvernementale vous parlait des chèques
vous parlez de fiasco pourquoi fiasco
d'abord je n'ai aucune leçon à donner
encore une fois si vous voulez je suis
d'abord un peu en colère parce que en
2004 c'est l'autorité du président
Chirac j'avais proposé un plan de
pandémie avec le professeur Anne-Claude
Cremieux nous avions écrit ce plan tout
était prévu tout était concret
un mode d'emploi il fallait l'utiliser
tout était prévu en cas de pandémie nous
avions eu quelques débuts de feu de
strass 2003 en Chine et on voyait bien
qu'un jour on pourrait quand même avoir
une épidémie la dernière vraiment où il
y a eu des millions et des millions des
dizaines de millions de morts c'était la
Cup espagnol 1919 on se disait ça va pas
être revenir bon et donc on voyait qu'il
n'y avait pas de plan pain débit tout
était prévu donc nous avions dit si
jamais virus arrive par tel endroit
qu'on arrête les avions qui viennent de
ces zones ont réquisitionne les
industries textiles pour faire des
masques on stocke des masques et puis
cette administration française qui a été
là
l'administration française qui a été la
première au monde à savoir faire le
premier pané premier plan de contre la
pandémie dans le monde a été la première
aussi à l'ignorer au point que nous
étions totalement dépourvu au mois de
février dernier
d'un problème dans la chaîne de
commandement très clair il faudrait
presque un monsieur crise sanitaire qui
pourrait être nommé en cas de crise mais
je voudrais qu'on revienne sur la
gestion elle-même la principale erreur
selon vous c'est quoi les masques
principalement non en fait sur les
masques le Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe l'a dit avant-hier dans cette
maison il est dit on m'a jamais séparé
de masques entre 2017 quand j'arrive à
Matignon et mi-janvier 2020 et arrêté il
y avait un milliard 700 millions un
milliard 700 millions de masques stockés
en 2011 et lorsqu'il pose la question le
15 janvier 2020 il y en a plus que 117
donc il y a une commission d'enquête
cette maison qui dira et qui dira
pourquoi comment et qui mais non vous me
posez la question Quels sont les deux
grands yeux en fait il y a deux grands
sujets le premier c'est février mars
2020 le dépistage massif pourquoi ce
pays n'a pas décidé de faire un
dépistage massif vous avez vu que sur
tous les plateaux de télévision les
scientifiques les médecins personne
n'était d'accord sur rien sauf sur une
chose c'est que plus vous dépistez moins
vous avez de morts à la sortie
notamment vous savez que c'est ce qui
s'est passé dans les hôpitaux c'est que
le dépistage n'était pas toujours
possible
il y avait simplement ce pays et un des
trois pays au monde à avoir le plus de
machines RTPCR par tête d'habitants et
donc pourquoi je vais vous dire les
tests avec l'écouillons dans le nez le
PCR vous êtes vous n'avez pas le virus
pourquoi je vais vous dire pourquoi
c'est parce que les seules machines
abidité référencées par le ministère de
la santé était celle qui avait le tampon
du ministère de la Santé et ce n'était
que dans les hôpitaux universitaires et
donc tous ceux qui étaient dans les
laboratoires toutes les machines qui
étaient élaboratoires privées toutes les
machines qui étaient dans les écoles
vétérinaires toutes les machines qui
étaient dans unités insecm CNRS INRIA
elle ne servait à rien alors qu'un
Allemagne à côté le professeur drusden
que l'équivalent du professeur Raoult
administrative on n'a pas mobilisé tout
le matériel disponible et donc c'est moi
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
fonctionnaires du ministère de la santé
des affaires sociales mais là il y a eu
en fait le c'est le principe du
parapluie dire que depuis l'histoire de
son contaminé ce pays c'est tous les
fonctionnaires savent que s'ils sortent
de la circulaire ils peuvent être
pénalement responsables et donc personne
n'a osé le faire il y a le rapport de du
professeur Suisse Didier Pittet qui
parle des lourdeurs administratives de
la bureaucratie et pourtant si on lit ce
rapport
on s'en est pas si mal tiré la gestion
n'a pas permis de nous mettre en fin de
classement c'est ce rapport il reconnaît
des erreurs mais
ce qu'on sait c'est des chiffres
de paix c'est le taux de mortalité alors
regardez
nos voisins allemands et le taux de
mortalité que nous avons quatre fois
quatre c'est beaucoup 4 quand vous avez
30000 morts quatre fois on est dans la
moyenne je ne disais
c'est parce que c'est le dépistage
massif donc c'est pour ça que je me
permets de vous dire c'est pour ça que
j'ai écrit ce livre c'est pas du tout
pour donner des mauvais points à qui que
ce soit si pour essayer de moi je fais
pas de politique politicienne avec ça je
ne fais pas de leçons ministre de la
Santé je me le permettrai pas je sais ce
que c'est ce travail là c'est très
difficile et moi je n'ai pas eu une
crise comme celle-là donc je vais pas ça
ce que je dis c'est qu'il faut plus
qu'on fasse les mêmes choses donc là le
dépistage massif nous avons eu beaucoup
de morts parce qu'on n'a pas dépisté
massivement une personne n'a fait en
France par contre c'était à Marseille
ces fameuses que devant l'IHU de
Marseille tout le monde se moquait deux
sauf qu'aujourd'hui si on revient à
l'échelle nationale on y est dans le
dépistage massif on est un million de
tests par semaine donc ce dépistage
massif il l'a fait du coup il y a pas de
surmortalité aujourd'hui c'est les
chiffres du ministère de la Santé pas de
immortel pas de surmortalité à Marseille
ni en janvier ni en février mars avril
mai juin deuxième
erreur après le test les tests comme
vous disiez nous mais non on teste V de
dire ça et c'est là l'erreur c'est que
cette fois-ci il faut tester mais il
faut pas tester il faut tester
rapidement et donc les tests PCR rapide
à 24 heures c'est fondamental parce que
s'il est délais d'attente du rendez-vous
et du résultat dépasse 4-5 jours ça ne
sert à rien de le dépistage vous dit il
y a 40 000 nous savons personnes par
jour mais deux jours d'attente pour
avoir le résultat qui avait encore
mais le ministère de la Santé le
reconnaît
d'abord on pourrait faire des tests
spécial beaucoup plus rapidement mais
non venons au testigénique cela donne
des réponses très vite mais alors il
faut pas les mettre à Orly comme
j'entends il faut les mettre dans tous
les cabinets médicaux chez tous les
pharmaciens chez toutes les infirmières
et demain ça sera des autotests pour que
les Français eux-mêmes avant d'aller au
théâtre ou avant d'aller au cinéma
pourront eux-mêmes tester mais il faut
le faire très vite on va parler si vous
le voulez bien Philippe boustebezy à
présent d'un sujet qui fâche
l'hydroxychlorocrine il y en a un qui
estime qu'au fond vous êtes un peu
culotté d'avoir fait la promotion de de
ce de ce traitement aujourd'hui et de
faire aujourd'hui elles sont au
gouvernement c'est lui écoutez
quant à la tribune qui a été publiée
récemment par un ancien ministre de la
Santé je l'ai parcouru avec intérêt
[Musique]
lui appartient évidemment de juger comme
il l'entend la façon dont la crise a été
gérée je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher et
pardon de revenir sur un sujet délicat
j'avais pas pu m'empêcher de constater
que c'était le même ancien ministre de
la Santé qui s'était illustré au début
de la crise par des prises de position
sans nuance sur le recours à certains
éléments thérapeutiques dont je ne suis
pas certain qu'ils aient pu être
démontrés par la suite je suis même
assez certain du contraire voilà il
parle de vous très clairement Philippe
bouste Blazy et de ce traitement de
l'hydroxyclorique chloroquine dont on
sait aujourd'hui qu'il ne marche pas
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez et
d'abord premièrement ce n'est pas vrai
si vous voulez c'est ça je ne veux pas
du tout Édouard Philippe qui n'est pas
un spécialiste de ces sujets et donc je
peux très bien comprendre très bien son
amertume c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est que
qui dit dépistage massif qu'il n'a pas
fait
c'est exactement l'erreur qu'il ne faut
pas faire donc permettez-moi de vous le
dire voilà vous faites une erreur parce
que vous dites hydroxy chloroquine et
moi je vous réponds dépistage massifs
parce que en réalité qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé à Marseille une fois que vous
dépistez massivement vous êtes très
mauvaise à Marseille aujourd'hui
monsieur Trump
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi il y a
un rapport extrêmement étroit entre le
dépistage massif mais écoutez bien
dépistage massif et hydroxychloroquine
voilà parce que quand vous dépistez
massivement vous avez des cas précoces
et vous vous a pas échappé en lisant les
journaux qu'il y a quatre phases dans la
maladie la première phase c'est la phase
précoce virale et donc si vous prenez si
vous avez ou si j'ai moi la covid ce
soir ou demain je vous conseille de
prendre la saturation d'oxygène et
immédiatement de prendre un antiviral
que ce soit
hydroxychoroquines
ou un autre la période j'ai compris
simplement le Premier ministre dit
ça ne marche pas
je vous dis que quand c'est la période
précoce évidemment les antiviraux quand
c'est la période purement
anti-inflammatoire où il faut des
anti-inflammatoires et l'oral
cytokinique alors là évidemment
ça ne sert à rien voilà je vous propose
de regarder un sujet de Maïté Frémont
qui va revenir sur ce feuilleton qui a
été scientifique mais qui a été aussi
très politique autour de la personne du
professeur Didier Raoul regardez vous
réagissez après
la covid arrive tout juste en France et
déjà Didier Raoult l'affirme
respiratoires la plus facile à traiter
de tout
le microbiologiste aurait trouvé la
solution miracle un simple médicament
que tout le monde connaît une molécule
pour lutter notamment contre le
paludisme
ce médicament on le connaît mieux que
tous les médicaments au monde c'est il y
a des milliers de gens qui ont mangé de
la chloroquine on sait très bien comment
ça quelle est sa pharmacocinétique
comment ça fonctionne après il va
falloir ajuster le meilleur traitement
la meilleure ce que nous on appelle la
posologie le meilleur nombre de
comprimés qu'on doit donner par jour
suffit-il d'avaler de simples comprimés
de chloroquines trois fois par jour pour
vaincre le virus l'équipe de Didier
Raoult est convaincu de son efficacité
et tente de le prouver études à l'appui
des études bien loin de faire
l'unanimité
en plein confinement devant l'iachu de
Marseille des centaines de Français font
la queue pour accéder au précieux
médicament
dans mon entourage et des gens qui sont
du domaine médical et qui font confiance
à ce traitement donc comme je leur fais
confiance je suis prête à expérimenter
oui mais très vite voilà le temps de la
controverse on n'est pas en train de
parler de bonbons ou de couleur de
cheveux on est en train de parler de
médicaments avec potentiellement des
risques on n'a pas le temps
d'expérimenter sur des souris pendant 6
mois et à partir du moment où il y a une
solution testée déjà sur un certain
nombre de patients qui semblent porter
leurs fruits je ne vois pas pourquoi la
France se priverait la chloroquine
devient une affaire politique et c'est
toute la France qui se divise entre les
pros et les anticloroquines la preuve
avec cette pétition de vous monsieur
douce de Blazy en faveur de la
chloroquine je vous demande avec le
professeur Pérol et avec beaucoup
d'autres de signer la pétition qui
permettra à tous les médecins français
de pouvoir prescrire l'hydroxyde
chloroquine c'est le souhaitent aux
patients atteints de covid 19
symptomatique un avis qui n'est pas
partagé par le gouvernement le Conseil
exclu toute prescription dans la
population générale ou pour des formes
non sévères à ce stade en l'absence
dit-il de toutes donner probante devant
la position du gouvernement Didier
Raoult claque la porte du conseil
scientifique il a été tenté de faire une
vraie évaluation de de l'hydroxycloquine
avec la citromycine mais la mise en
place de ça a été tardive et que donc le
test mais il y a aucune évaluation
d'essai du tout qui a été mis en place
par ce conseil scientifique c'est une
faillite totale rien du tout rien six
mois après l'annonce plusieurs études
scientifiques du monde entier le
démontre
la chloroquine ne fonctionne pas sur la
covid mais ça ne décourage pas le
professeur Raoult qui se dote de son
propre conseil scientifique
voilà on l'a appris aujourd'hui l'agence
du médicament vient de refuser
l'utilisation de la chloroquine Philippe
Douste Blazy vous n'avez pas de regret
d'avoir appelé dans cette pétition à les
médecins à l'utiliser alors
dans ce livre j'essaie d'être vraiment
le plus objectif possible et j'ai dit
que je respecte totalement ce qui était
contre et je respecte ce qui était pour
j'ai essayé d'expliquer ce qui s'est
passé pardonnez-moi mais vous avez une
série d'études scientifiques reconnus
publiée dans les plus grandes revues
internationales recovery étude
britannique étude de l'Inserm et ses
cliniques conduits par des équipes
américaines brésiliennes toute la
littérature scientifique aujourd'hui est
au clair ça ne marche pas je peux vous
donner exactement le même qui dit le
contraire le même recovery on y va
recovery est-ce que vous savez quand à
quel moment on a donné
l'hydroxycloroquines et à combien de
grammes dites-moi parce que vous en
parlez je suis pas spécialiste alors
j'ai fait la liste je regarde l'A ence
du médicament
toutes les instants je vous parle vous
me parlez de
records si vous prenez le Vidal c'est
une dose létale voilà donc aujourd'hui
vous avez des études rétrospectives qui
montrent que hydroxycloroquine marche
tout à fait au début de la forme virale
de la maladie et je vais vous en trouver
mais d'aller plus grandes revues
mondiales et puis vous avez d'autres qui
disent en effet que ça ne fonctionne pas
pourquoi parce qu'on ne donne pas les
dropsychoroqués
au monde c'est pour ça que j'étais très
étonné que votre journaliste disent
qu'il était clos parce qu'il est
évidemment pas que ce que l'on sait
c'est que deux choses c'est que le
traitement
miracle contre la covid n'existe pas et
donc
le moment il y en a pas non mais vous
avez pas me disant anti-inflammatoires
par exemple aujourd'hui on sait que les
antigènes on sait que la cortisone dès
l'instant où vous êtes en période
inflammatoire ça fonctionne on sait que
les antiviraux de la première phase à
condition de faire un dépistage massif
et précoce alors aussi ça fonctionne
vous l'avez suivi cette commission
d'enquête la plupart la communauté
scientifique lui reproche de n'a pas
avoir fait d'étude publiées d'études
scientifiques les randomisés en double
aveugle j'explique il faut que le groupe
traité et le groupe contrôle soit
identique ça n'était pas le cas il y a
pas un problème aussi du côté des études
produits dans le livre j'en parle
beaucoup
le taux de mortalité de la covid et de
0,5%
pour faire la différence entre
l'efficacité sur la mortalité d'un
traitement par rapport à un groupe
contrôle d'après vous combien il faut de
personnes je ne suis pas spécialiste
il faut des milliers de personnes et
donc il faudrait attendre plusieurs mois
voire plusieurs années pour avoir la
réponse donc on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
par rapport à cela si vous voulez les
études observationnelles et là il y a
tout un débat aujourd'hui d'un côté
scientifique sur les sur les sur les
choses observationnelles lui il a choisi
il a choisi des études observationnelles
bon il y a eu des études chez lui dans
son hôpital qui n'ont pas été habillés
il y a une discussion mais là ce que
vous dites pas non plus et une chose
extrêmement importante et sur le plan
politique dans une maison comme ici je
voudrais le dire c'est que moi je suis
un scientifique je suis un médecin je
suis une épidémiologiste c'est la
première fois de ma vie que je vois un
scandale de cette manière ou le landset
qui est un des plus grands journaux au
monde
la reconnu elle était frauduleuse là je
vous ai cité des revues n'étaient pas
critiquées
de la médecine qui sont des grands
journaux et qui restent des grands
journaux ont publié des études fausses
de gens que je connais avec qui j'avais
pu j'ai j'ai fait des cours à Harvard
donc je les connais bien et bien les
méthodologies ils ont donné leur donner
à des statisticiens qui ont fait des
faux j'espère que les enquêtes
américaines
il fait il fait de la publicité
vous le savez mais vous me posez des
questions vous accepteriez un débat avec
un autre épidémiologiste sur ce plateau
d'y voir un public un peu plus clair ça
s'appelle maladie française très facile
par le professeur Didier Raoult pandémie
et pourtant tout avait été préparé tout
de suite le bloc note
[Musique]
bonsoir François Durpaire bonsoir merci
d'être là Thomas des prés bonsoir et
Camille saferis qui va nous préparer
vous allez voir Philippe Douste Blazy un
petit apéro avec un député comme vous ne
l'avez jamais vu mais on va commencer
avec Alex Taylor qui est par Skype avec
nous et qui va nous parler de
l'interminable feuilleton du brexit
bonsoir Alex nouveau rebondissements au
Parlement britannique dans les deux
chambres c'est bien ça oui Myriam
l'enfer ne connaît pas de Fiori plus
féroce que celle d'une femme méprisée ce
dicton anglais vient à l'esprit cette
semaine ou deux femmes qui ont
particulièrement marqué la politique
britannique ces dernières années ont
exprimé leur colère à l'égard de Johnson
dans chaque chambre comme une éloge et
de chaque bord politique commençant avec
Theresa May et oui on se tient un
premier ministre ici plus pertinemment
ancienne ministre de l'Intérieur
regardez sa tête lorsque son ex collègue
lui charger du notaire à l'autre cuit
danse d'affirmer que les Britanniques
seront écoutez bien davantage en
sécurité une fois qu'ils n'auront plus
accès aux données de la police
européenne on voit ça stupéfaction dans
un énorme what
donc bien des domaines notre coopération
sera plus efficace une fois hors l'Union
européenne
nous disposons d'une multitude d'outils
de renseignements et de sécurité que
nous pourrons intensifier
alors ça c'est pour la Chambre des
communes comment ça s'est passé côté
Lord
et oui là c'est mon égérie
ancienne député travailliste ancienne
danseuse de cancan et fut prise dans les
années 30 et surtout première femme
speaker des communes la meilleure
d'ailleurs un petit rappel du temps de
Blair il y a 25 ans pour situer le
personnage
[Musique]
et cette semaine la voilà entre temps
devenue la baronne
Hollande à 92 ans mais qui n'a pas perdu
un ongle de sa griffe furieuse que
Johnson compte de pas respecter le
traité que lui et du coup la
Grande-Bretagne a signé avec l'Union
européenne écoutez là
mais l'ordre
était élu il y a 47 ans
j'ai vu 9 premiers ministres franchir le
seuil du 10 Street
témoin d'un écroulement aussi rapide de
la confiance du peuple dans un
gouvernement qui a tant promis si vite
et qui cherche désespérément des
solutions qu'il prétendaient alors si
facile
une chose dont je suis certaine on ne
méritera pas notre réputation
on ne regagnera pas le respect que nous
devons à nous-mêmes tant que le monde ne
saura à nouveau que nous respectons à la
fois notre parole et la loi
cet accent britannique a coupé couteau
merci beaucoup à Alex ce feuilleton du
brexit qui non finit plus on va partir
maintenant outletic avec vous François
vous avez regardé vous êtes couté chez
tard à nouveau comme souvent
et vous avez regardé pour nous le
dernier débat Trump byden que retenir
d'abord la première chose c'est un vrai
débat politique il y a pas eu
d'interruption parce que Christian
Walker votre concurrent de la NBC avait
un petit bouton qui permettait de faire
taire notamment Donald Trump et donc de
l'interrompre comme ça ah oui vous en
rêvez et donc là
ils sont tenus c'était aussi aux
États-Unis imaginable c'était nouveau et
donc finalement c'est Joe Biden qui est
sorti assez gagnant on va voir sur les
images un tout petit peu de de body
language vous allez voir que il est pour
quelqu'un d'endormir c'était
l'expression un slow slow Biden sleepy
Joe vous voyez tout le temps il montre
son adversaire du doigt et Donald Trump
lui avec ce geste là de la main alors là
c'est le moment où il montre il fait des
mimes il était vraiment très actif dans
ce débat et donc chercher à montrer
qu'il peut être
ce commandant en chef dont certains
doutes ça c'est la première chose après
sur le fond il y a eu l'effet boomerang
parce que on sait que Donald Trump
voulait attaquer Joe Biden sur son fils
hunterbiddle alors on va voir exactement
mais vous receviez beaucoup d'argent de
la Russie ils vont payer beaucoup
d'argent ils le font probablement encore
jamais de ma vie je n'ai pris un centime
d'une source étrangère nous avons appris
que ce président a payé 50 fois plus
d'impôts en Chine un compte bancaire
secret en Chine fait des affaires en
Chine et il dit que c'est moi qui prend
de l'argent
voilà il fait boomerang lors du premier
débat lorsqu’il attaquait de manière
personnelle Joe Biden disait non on va
parler du fond on va parler aux
Américains là non il avait prévu ces
petites fiches vous avez touché 50 fois
les impôts que vous touche que vous
payez aux États-Unis il avait prévu
d'attaquer et de dire bah vous aussi
vous enfants ont fait la même chose que
ne te que que mon fils donc c'était
c'était vraiment là un passage très très
important mais peut-être que ça s'est
pas joué là ça s'est joué dès le départ
quand
Christian Walker a dit et bien depuis la
dernière fois qu'on s'est vu enfin
depuis le premier débat 16000 américains
sont morts de la covid 19 dès la
première phrase le décor était planté et
à la fin à la fin c'était la carte
blanche elle a dit qu'est-ce que vous
allez dire aux Américains pour qu'ils
votent pour pour vous et Donald Trump a
répondu voilà mon bilan et il a fait le
bilan d'avant la covid-19 voilà j'avais
ça j'avais ce taux de chômage
etc on s'est dit on s'est pincé en
disant mais là il est en train de nous
faire le bilan d'il y a plusieurs mois
et pas le Big Bang d'aujourd'hui alors
ça veut pas dire qu'il a déjà perdu il
faut savoir aussi ça c'est une
particularité de cette année c'est que
presque 50 millions d'Américains ont
déjà voté par anticipation par
anticipation ou par correspondance ce
qui fait qu'évidemment il y avait bien
beaucoup d'Américains devant la
télévision mais certains étaient
évidemment déjà voté non pas n'ont pas
été convaincus par l'un ou par l'autre
puisque c'était déjà fait
il reste 12 jours et on nous dit
François nous dit que Donald Trump n'a
pas forcément perdu
c'est à dire qu'en fait très
curieusement nous c'est difficile pour
nous de le comprendre parce qu'on est
habitué à une certaine type d'élection
présidentielle la démocratie n'est pas
parfaite là-bas et donc tout va se jouer
dans ce qu'on appelle les swing States
c'est à dire le fleuriste Michigan le
Wisconsin Sylvanie et cette année c'est
même le texte cette année et donc ça par
contre c'est évidemment la grande
inconnue et comme vous l'avez très bien
dit tout peut encore se passer mais
j'espère quand même que voilà enfin bon
on verra
la victoire de Joe Biden vous pouvez le
dire si c'est ce que vous espérez allez
Thomas des prés Thomas Després qui va
nous raconter qui nous raconte sa
journée à l'Assemblée mais qui le
vendredi nous fait une petite
compilation vous avez envie de nous
parler des temps forts qui ont cartonné
sur le compte Twitter LCP exactement les
deux moments forts de l'actualité
parlementaire repérés par la cellule web
de LCP qui ont fait le buzz pendant
toute la semaine et forcément il a
encore été question de la crise
sanitaire les députés poursuivent leur
travail de la commission d'enquête pour
tenter de comprendre les
dysfonctionnements de la première vague
ils auditionnaient à cette semaine
l'ancien Premier ministre Edouard
Philippe et pour la première fois il est
revenu sur ses déclarations affirmant
que le port du masque n'était pas utile
un premier mea culpa c'était mercredi
après-midi
j'ai fait des erreurs dans la
communication comme beaucoup d'autres
comme nous en pouvons faire tous j'en ai
fait quelques-unes j'ai dit à 13h de TF1
que le port du masque en population
générale n'avait aucun sens pourquoi
est-ce que je l'ai dit parce qu'on me
l'avait dit
parce que des médecins l'avaient dit
parce que c'était la doctrine qui n'a
changé que bien après qu'il le disait
est-ce qu'il aurait dû le dire de façon
beaucoup plus prudente
pour me préserver moi où est-ce que je
devais le dire de la façon la plus
convaincante parce que c'était la
doctrine
j'ai pas encore exactement la réponse à
cette question sur le député
vous réagissez à se met à culpa
je pense qu'il a eu tout à fait raison
de dire cela mais j'avais plus loin je
pense que
ce serait extrêmement grave que Édouard
Philippe en tant qu' ancien Premier
ministre soit considéré comme
responsable pénalement on l'a connu avec
l'histoire du son contaminé avec Fabius
parce que vous ne trouverez jamais plus
personne qui acceptera bien évidemment
des responsabilités politiques si vous
continuez comme ça en réalité comme il a
très bien dit on lui a dit il y a des
gens qui sont là pour ça donc il vaut
mieux peut-être aller chercher les gens
qui sont responsabilités de ce genre de
dossier et là en effet on peut
comprendre on comprendrait pas pourquoi
au ministère de la Santé quelqu'un a dit
du masque ne sert à rien mais aller
chercher les ministres lui-même je pense
que vous allez avoir on va voir un gros
problème il a reconnu d'ailleurs que le
risque pénal avait pesé dernière extrait
Thomas clash entre la France insoumise
et le ministre Olivier Véran oui c'est
ce qui a fait le plus gros buzz cette
semaine sur les réseaux sociaux L est
venu présenter la loi de prorogation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire l'occasion
d'une question de Daniel obono et d'une
réponse musclée est-ce que la stratégie
du gouvernement est vraiment efficace
comment se fait-il que nous n'ayons pas
aujourd'hui réussis à dire identifier
90% semble-t-il des lieux où les
contaminations auraient lieu ça pose
question sur comment on pourrait on peut
mettre en oeuvre une stratégie la plus
adaptée possible si on ne sait pas où
ont lieu la majorité des contaminations
votre groupe parlementaire depuis le
début a voté contre tout vous avez voté
contre l'état d'urgence vous avez voté
contre la sortie de l'état d'urgence
vous avez voté contre les mesures
dérogatoires de sortie d'état d'urgence
vous avez voté contre les systèmes
d'information de contact Racing vous
avez même voté contre les systèmes
d'information qui permettent
d'enregistrer les tests positives pour
prévenir les patients vous avez voté
contre tout donc moi je vous pose la
question je vous pose la question
s'il vous plaît que vous avez à proposer
face l'épidémie qui remplit les hôpitaux
encore une fois moi j'entends je ne dis
pas que nous avons la science infuse et
que l'ensemble de la communauté
scientifique et médicale et l'ensemble
des juristes qui travaillent auprès du
gouvernement ou même de manière
indépendante dans les organismes
indépendants forcément raison je dis
qu'on est ouvert au contribution enfin à
votre compte n'est pas une contribution
bon c'est musclé c'est pas un clash
fondamental c'est ça reste voilà c'est
ce qui en tout cas le plus fait réagir
les internautes cette semaine merci
Thomas on en vient à ma séquence
préférée de la semaine Camille ça fait
rire ce qui nous va nous faire découvrir
d'ailleurs l'un de vos ex-collèdes les
républicains Philippe Gosselin Philippe
Gosselin député des républicains de la
Manche depuis 2007 il vient des Marais
du Cotentin et alors il est catholiques
très pratiquant Philippe Gosselin alors
vous avez vu la phrase du pape hier
alors finalement alors il a participé
Philippe Gosselin au JMJ à Rome en 86
quand même vous voyez c'est un bon alors
je lui ai posé la question qui
s'imposait les JMJ il paraît que c'est
sympa pour les rencontres vrai ou faux
forcément que c'est vrai quand c'est pas
parce que vous êtes catho d'abord que
vous tombez pas amoureux les petites
jeunes cathos sont comme tous les jeunes
de leur âge ça a rien de coincé je vous
assure c'est aussi des copains quand
même leur guitare il y a cette ambiance
à la fois de de recueillement de joie
d'une certaine façon on peut aller
chanter dans les rues de Rome parce
qu'on n'est pas toujours le chapelet à
la main je vous assure on n'est pas
toujours non plus avec la croix et la
bannière non plus on rigole on a 20 ans
on est de son époque et puis aussi on
est
en admiration devant un pape moi je suis
gipitou ou quoi Jean-Paul II forever
très investi aussi Philippe Bresson dans
la lutte contre la contrefaçon alors il
nous il va nous lister maintenant donc
les objets qui circulent en ce moment
parce qu'il y a pas que les petits polos
avec le petit crocodiles bien sûr il y
en a plein d'autres des produits de la
vie courante par exemple
le lait maternisé on a eu il y a
quelques années aussi des affaires assez
terribles des fausses
plaques ou plaquettes de de frein vous
avez des pare-chocs qui sont aussi
trafiqués etc vous avez aussi un fameux
médicament petite pilule bleue qui ne
sont pas des smarties
ça ressemble au smarties c'est ça peut
faire peut-être un double effet qui se
coule mais qui sont aussi les
médicaments qu'on retrouve le plus et en
contrefaçon sur internet alors là c'est
vous ne le savez en général qu'après
vous ne savez qu'après quand vous avez
fait votre crise cardiaque enfin bref
voilà donc et là je le dis un peu de
façon badine mais mais il y a de grand
risque
il y a parfois du recyclage d'idées
un peu de François Hollande qui soit pas
du tout du même bord mais ils ont un
point commun avec François Hollande
c'est un joyeux de rire film que ça
c'est un jeu d'Auré notamment un
imitateur amateur très performant qui
est disponible pour toutes vos soirées
anniversaire battez mon mariage
démonstration ça fait quelques langues
années cher ami que j'aimais déjà Chirac
et quelques autres n'est-ce pas alors on
s'en amuse mais je ne voudrais pas
aujourd'hui insister car je voudrais pas
que Maman arrive et me fiche un coup
dans la chaux-de-fond à bien mais cher
compatriotes et oui je vous ai compris
vous n'auriez pas vu ma voiture non pas
d'abord c'est pas ma voiture c'est mon
vélo ou alors qu'est-ce que je vais
devenir
un piéton
alors bah franchement c'est vraiment pas
juste là
j'adore mais vous êtes extraordinaire il
me l'avez jamais fait moi merci beaucoup
j'aurais adoré vous disiez au revoir
avec l'accent Jacques Chirac vous savez
la prochaine fois merci beaucoup
Philippe Douste Blazy merci à tous les
amis c'est la fin de cette émission
excellent weekend à tous profitez bien
[Musique]